hey guys Ryan Wright here and today I'm
gonna be watchin three TV spots for
Godzilla the 2014 movie anyway a lot of
people have been asking that I watch
this and I'm excited to see it because
[ __ ] it's Godzilla man Gojira he's the
[ __ ]
so enough chitter-chatter stop talking
just shut up watch the damn TV spot
already whoa
you stopped for a second it looks so
creepy
good it's such an eerie trailer oh man
they're like you know ways that little
bell that goes off and it goes a little
silent that's just creepy
all right TV spot number DOS this one's
called believe this is happening okay
that's the last Vegas people keep
talking about that annoys me
Wow damn he looks so scary
whoa may 16 into the 9x 3d that's right
you better experience that [ __ ] in IMAX
3d good teaser you get to see a little
bit more of Aaron taylor-johnson
emotional character anytime you see
Bryan Cranston it's 10 times more
intense at one section where he was just
running you're like oh [ __ ] he's running
from something it's probably Godzilla
here we go TV spot number three
they evacuated us so quickly
whoa a 16 X perience at an IMAX 3d dude
the way they're showing Godzilla I
[ __ ] love it because it's just like
little tiny glimpses of him and I hope
the movie actually kind of does that
where it does look a more realistic that
way where it's like you sometimes see
him and but then again he's this giant
monster so if you sometimes only see him
then something must be wrong with your
vision today yeah all three TV spots
combined make one hell of a trailer you
know they're really setting up Aaron
taylor-johnson is character they're
really starting to Bryan Cranston's
character they're establishing one hell
of a scary tone this movie is gonna be
intense it's gonna be one hell of a
monster epic so excited please subscribe
see how I did that top that off with a
subscribe button a new way of talking
about this button up here and of course
it's that time of the video where I
mentioned a few subscribers so I want to
mention some newer ones some more recent
subscribers Callisto X hot ass thumbnail
not entirely sure if that's you or not
can't tell of a terma movie but that is
a cute girl on that thumbnail if that is
you you and I should meet up and cuddle
zio Dubois this dude left like a billion
comments love him because he is so
interactive with the videos he like
review daily review that is awesome
who does that zo dubious does Jamie
Smith he called dibs on a shout-out
so what ha dibs on the shout out hope I
said that right
or is it Christ iñaki are you of the
bloodline of our Lord and Savior